cela fait maintenant quatre jours que
les armes se sont tues à gaza
alors les habitants de l'enclavé
commence à croire en la solidité du
cessez le feu
assez en tout cas pour se lancer dans un
grand ménage
et commencer à envisager des lendemains
plus normaux
mais la normalité ne fait pas partie du
vocabulaire à l'hôpital al-shifa malgré
la trêve le plus grand centre
hospitalier de gaza reste débordés cet
homme vient d'arriver en arrêt cardio
respiratoire
tout le personnel disponible est appelée
en renfort pour des manoeuvres de
réanimation le docteur al haitham chef
des urgences dirige les soins le
pronostic est très mauvaise il avant de
constater le décès l'homme est arrivé
trop tard comme tout le monde ici
le docteur al haitham n'a pas un instant
de répit nous n'avons que onze lits aux
urgences dit-il alors qu'on a déjà 40
patients et que ça continue d'arriver
après la pandémie et les onze jours de
bombardements
le personnel médical et surmené épuisé
démoralisé aussi car il a payé un lourd
tribut nous avons perdu trois docteurs
et 10 infirmières dit il fauché par des
bombes et des explosions
avant le confirmer
l'hôpital al shifa n'était pas si
différent des autres hôpitaux de la
planète en ce sens qu'il était déjà
débordés en raison des quatre
coronavirus et des bombardements
israéliens n'ont vraiment pas aidé la
situation
car parmi les trois médecins tués
figurait le chef de l'unité qu'au fil de
l'hôpital avec la guerre son remplaçant
a dû faire des choix difficiles à
évacuer les patients qu'aux vide en
situation critique pour libérer des lits
vos soins intensifs on a seulement 3
respirateur artificiel dit il et on en
avait vraiment besoin de coronavirus a
déjà contaminé plus de 100000 gazaouis
et fait plus de 800 morts
le docteur awad créent maintenant un
nouveau pic de contagion conséquence
directe de la guerre en à peine une
heure cinq patients se sont présentés
ici avec des symptômes qui laisse peu de
doute c'est probablement le début d'une
troisième vague dit il expliquant que
les gens ont dû se réfugier en grand
nombre dans des abris pendant les
bombardements sans masque ni distance
il faut dire qu'ici à peine 3 % de la
population a été vaccinée contre 53% en
israël difficile dans ces conditions
d'être optimiste ici jean françois
bélanger radio-canada gaza